hi welcome I'm Mike an engineering
manager on the Google Play console and
I'm very happy to be here today to talk
to you about a subject
there's particularly important to my
team and I and that is enabling success
on Android through safe controlled
effective at police's we know from
yourselves from our own experience and
the experience of other teams at Google
that releasing new apps and updates it's
what you might describe as an exciting
time it's the time when all that hard
work the whole team has been putting in
finally gets into the hands of your
users and that is an incredible feeling
users are going to be delighted by your
new functionality and improved
performance business metrics are going
to go through the roof and everyone is
going to be catching on to that good
kind of excitement in essence for a good
release we need to delight users with
new experiences we need to maintain and
improve those important business metrics
and of course we need to get that tech
right to deliver a stable high quality
product simple right
but releases they also present us with
some challenges we need to keep our
existing users happy we need to make
sure we're actually improving those key
performance indicators and of course not
introduce performance regressions or
bugs and if we do get this wrong it can
lead to an altogether different kind of
excitement a miscalculated release may
result in crashes and bad user
experience and this can have a prompt
immeasurable impact we crunch some
numbers on the subject and our data
shows users are 26% more likely to give
one-star reviews on the days when your
app is that is crushed for games this
increases to a staggering 52% more
star ratings similarly in reviews for
reviews given on those crassius days
uses a 38 percent more likely to mention
stability and bugs and as you might
expect this is not just limited to
ratings in the store key performance
indicators are also affected engagement
metrics and in-store numbers also suffer
when your app is crashing on top of all
this let's take a moment to think about
the ecosystem in which we're operating
here at more than 2 billion active
devices Android is in fact the largest
software and computing platform on the
planet of course this presents
phenomenal opportunity for scale and
reach to influence an incredibly large
diverse set of users however it also
presents some unique challenges when it
comes to software deployment that
incredible diversity in users also comes
with unprecedented diversity in device
types with thousands of different makes
and models across a variety of different
form factors and so to have great
releases and to keep with that good kind
of excitement we need to listen and
validate functionality improvements by
collecting feedback from a
representative set of engaged
enthusiastic users we need to measure to
make sure we're having the right impact
on those key user and business metrics
and we need to optimize that technology
by detecting those bugs and stability
issues not only this but ideally we want
to do all this as early as possible
the sooner we catch problems the better
be them bugs usability issues or
business metric regressions the sooner
we catch problems the more the more
scalable our processes are the more
effective our teams can be and the
faster we can ship even more great
features and this is where the right
tools and release process comes in for
the next part of this session we're
walking through the suite of tools that
the
or play console makes available to help
you handle this process confidently and
effectively we'll look at deploying your
release to increasingly larger audiences
and what you can hope to achieve at each
phase to reach the ultimate goal of
deploying a great new Apple update to
everybody and after that we'll welcome
Barda from the Android system health
team to give us a deep dive on the
Google app release process we'll see how
teams at Google big and small are making
great use of these tools to scale their
release processes and so to begin all
that I'd like to welcome on stage serge
an engineer on the play console to talk
to us about the first phase of a release
testing
thanks Mike first I'd like to do a show
of hands who amongst you have published
an app in the Play console already Wow
okay and please keep your hands up if
you also have been using the alpha and
beta track for your app all right well
you guys are great I think you'll love
this talk of course for those who
haven't yet published an app in the Play
console a track is a way to define a
group of users to whom you can publish
your app for example there's the
production track which targets all the
over 2 billion Android users and then
there is the alpha and beta track which
targets a much smaller subset of users
of course before you publish your app to
the world testing your app with that
small group of users it's really
important for this is for catching bugs
issues but also to scale and move faster
key to this is distributing your test
version of your app to a small group of
users this could be either your wider
team product managers our QA team or
whoever can provide you with early
feedback there's lots of ways to do that
one way would be to simply email it BK's
to your users
well that's quite cumbersome and
actually it puts a lot of burden on
their shoulders
while the alpha and beta track can be
used for distributing Chesapeake ace we
heard from you that actually the alpha
and beta track are too slow for that
kind of fast iterative testing and this
is because as we'll see later the alpha
and beta track are designed for scale
testing with potentially millions of
users and the apk is published to those
tracks goes through processing that can
take several hours
to enable fast iterative testing we
introduced the internal test track the
internal test track is a new track in
the play console that is designed to
distribute test versions of your app to
a small group of users within your
organization let me show you how it
works
switching to the computer I have here I
have my test app that I created for this
demo call IO demo and I have it here in
the Play console this is the app release
this page and we can see I have the
production track the beta track the
alpha track and the new internal test
track you can see here I have version
actually I have version 49 already
published in a release in this track
version 49 here I have one tester for
this app switching to the device and you
can see this can you see on the device
very very soon
yes so this is my testers device and you
can see I have this IO demo app in the
launcher when I open it there's a single
activity and it shows the version code
I'm guessing that your app is a bit more
sophisticated if I go in the Play
console I can see that I don't have any
updates so the version code of my apk on
my testers device is the same one that
isn't the release that I rolled out in
the internal test track now my cure just
told me that actually my app doesn't
conform with the official Google IO
branding for the college team so I will
go and fix this and quickly distribute
an app to my tester going back to the
computer so we'll go to Android studio
here in Android studio I have my project
already open with my app I also have
installed the Gradle play publisher
plug-in which is set up so that it
automatically published the play console
updates and builds on
make of my app I have a great task here
we publish apk release and when I invoke
it it automatically pushes the general
test track to build on my app so I will
create a new version version 50 and then
I will change my color to what was it
again right space pineapple all right so
what will happen is that when I invoke
this Gradle task it will automatically
build the apk and then upload it to the
Play console to the internal test track
once the upload completes I will start
the timer here I have another device
with the timer and I start the timer to
2 hours I hope you guys are not in a
hurry this is because this is how long
you should expect it to take if I was to
publish this apk to the alpha or beta
track then I will go to the Play Store
on my testers device and it will check
for an update and as soon as the update
is available I will stop the timer and
we'll see how long it takes all right
sorry I start the task so let's switch
to the device place so Android studio is
building the apk and I started to upload
it of course I don't usually do this and
I want a Wi-Fi network in the tenth
share by 2000 people but hopefully it's
the words all right so now the upload
has completed if I go on my test this
device or I start the timer all right
I check for an update now my dump did
and it is here already so actually that
took less than 5 subtle so if I update
my app it installs the update now open
it and I have my new color scheme and
with my new version code
this is dramatically faster than
publishing to the alpha and beta track
as you can see it's quite amazing I've
been advised against doing a live demo
on stage at Google i/o with a real
device but you guys deserve it all right
so we've seen how you can publish to the
play console using a greater plugin in
Android studio but of course you can
also use the Play console UI to do just
that
the cheese you can set up testers sorry
give a side all right so you can set up
testers by specifying a list of email
addresses the testers opt in with a
single URL then the testers use the Play
Store app on the device to install and
update your app it's super simple for
testers to set up it works on any
Android device with the Play Store and
there's no special app or permission
it's fast safe and simple sorry my
there's two buttons here and 50% chance
of missing it all right in order to get
apk is out quickly we distribute them to
testers before the processing and of the
apk has completed
so although the publishing of the apk is
instant the apks and bundles published
in the internal test track are still
subject to play policies the update for
internal testers is also different than
from alpha beta so users can be either
alpha beta testers or internal testers
there is also a cap of a hundred testers
in the initial test rack per app the new
internal test track is supported by the
Play console publisher API and by many
play console publisher plugins so that
means that you can automate you can
automate publishing to the intro test
track very easily from your existing
tool chains and workflows you can get up
and running with very little change
The Enchantress track is great for quick
iteration during development for
catching bugs early for getting fast
evac for new team and also for testing
plane integration because your app is
published to play it reports all the
play features lvl testing in-app
purchases and most importantly the new
Android app bundle and dynamic delivery
features so interesting about trying out
those features the internal test track
is a great way to do that once you have
your app testing internally with the
internal test track you're ready for
real user although typically you not get
ready to open up to everyone you might
be looking for trusted feedback or maybe
a confidential set of features close
testing allows you to scale up your
testing while maintaining control of who
can get your app the alpha and beta
track have been supporting closed
testing for some time now but we heard
feedback that as your app scales the
alpha and beta track don't scale well
with various testing scenarios what if
for example you would like to test your
app with a track for each feature branch
or what if you would like to create a
new track for new events or milestones
well I'm delighted to announce that now
we can create new additional closed
testing tracks enabling all those
scenarios you now have one production
track one open testing track any number
of closed testing track and an internal
test track when you want to create an
additional closed testing track you can
just click on the button create closed
track choose any name you want and that
name is also used in the API from our
early adopters we have seen that this is
great for user studies countries
specific variants protein future
branches and testing in incrementally
larger groups
and just scratching the surface of how
those new tracks can be used for those
who have been using the alpha and beta
track you may have heard of pre-launch
report it takes aap kaise AAP case that
you publish to the Play console and
install them on ten different unique
devices and the test forms it runs your
app for five minutes at a time with Robo
for nearly an hour of testing in total
it shows crash reports performance
issues and security vulnerabilities
pre-launch report also added new ways to
control the crawl like robot scripts and
demo loop for games
there are announcing exciting new
features go see their awesome talk
tomorrow at 9:30 be sure to set an alarm
for that or if you like me and you still
wake up on the different time zone will
be set as we've seen close testing is
great for what you want to test your app
with a set of trusted testers but
typically the problem with those users
is that they're not very representative
of production users the publicity
production users have a wider set of
devices but then might not be as
motivated as trusted testers and might
engage with a different set of features
in your app when you want to have broad
coverage of your code find technical
issues or get more relevant business
metrics you can use open testing
releasing to open testing allow any user
to discover and join your testing
community directly from the Google Play
Store app on their device and this user
can provide you private feedback that
you can review in the Play console and
those feedbacks won't affect your public
ratings this is a great way to scale up
and to make sure that the new version of
your app provides a great experience to
users before you launch it to the world
if you need to you can also set a cap on
the number of testers or of users that
join that testing program to keep things
manageable of course open testing is
only as valuable
as users are willing to participate
today there are over 230 million users
who already opted in open test with two
and a half million users opting in each
week so it's really up to you to put it
to good use
late last year we also introduced the
new country targeting for testing tracks
with country targeting testing you can
now control the country availability for
each track individually this can be used
for both open and closed testing and
allows you to run a test in a different
set of countries to those in which a
production app is life we have seen some
of the features play provides to help
you test your app it's time to go to the
next step in the release process and for
that I'm going to hand it to Ritchie
neck under the engineer on the play
console who will talk to you about
rollouts
thanks Serge so you've tested internally
then in close groups and finally using
open testing you've polished the user
experience optimize those business
metrics and ironed out those bugs and
performance issues you're confident this
new release has it all the only thing
left to do is roll it out to the public
last i/o we unveiled a new gated release
flow for managing your release thank you
for all the feedback you provided based
on this input we've further streamlined
the process making it faster to provide
translated release notes and enhancing
the apk upload process so you can drag
and drop all your apks into your release
in a single step we have also introduced
support for instant apps instant games
actions on Android and the new Android
app bundle in preparation for the new
Android app bundle we've introduced the
new UI to help you understand the
contents of your apk or bundle even if
you aren't using Android app bundle this
provides useful insights into the sizes
of your apks keeping your apks as small
as possible means users can download and
install faster and have more free space
left for their photos and music on
average apps will see a 20% size
reduction by using android app bundle
and the bundle Explorer can show you
exactly the size saving you can achieve
for your app we recommend all developers
use staged rollouts when rolling out to
production staged rollouts allow you to
control the percentage of users eligible
to update and gradually increase this as
your confidence and the release grows
and the unlikely event that something
goes wrong you can also hold the release
well only a small percentage of users
are affected we're really happy to see
the sense
introducing the new gated release flow
twice as many of you are making use of
stage rollers
following on from this we have extended
stage rulers with the new country
targeted ruler option this allows you to
rule over country in addition to by
percentage this is really useful to
start your release in a market that you
have a deep understanding of making it
easier to understand your business
metrics as the ruler progresses once
your release is rolling out you can use
the release dashboard in the play
console to monitor key metrics such as
update rates and app ratings as well as
crashes and ANR's these metrics help you
evaluate your release and ensure remains
healthy as you proceed with the rollout
the statistics view now shows release
events making it even easier to
understand the impact of a rollout for a
more detailed view you can use the
vitals page to check metrics like
battery usage jank weight clock usage
and others well we've introduced many
exciting new features for releasing your
apps through the Play console we know
that many of you automate your apk
deployment with continuous integration
systems or using Gradle plugins as surge
dead earlier so we've updated the a
publishing API and from today you can
use these features and your automated
workflows rolling out a release via the
API now uses the same release model
you're familiar with from the Play
console this allows you to name your
release and more easily modify release
notes in addition we've relaxed the
constraints and what you can roll out
via the API to match the play console
the new testing tracks Serge mentioned
earlier are of course also now supported
by the API this is great for configuring
your continuous integration system to
push to your internal test track
whenever you have a new belt ready for
QA the new release model also unlocks
some features that were previously only
available via the Play console for
instance it's now possible to hold a
release using the publishing API this
allows you to fill your
to make your release process including
automatically responding to problems
we've heard from many of you that while
you're comfortable rolling out test
modes via the API you like the control
of coming to the console when rolling
out to production so with the updated
API we've added the ability to create
and manage draft releases via the API
this means you can stage a draft release
from your continuous integration system
and then have your product manager login
check everything looks good and hat
confirm and roll out you can find the
full details of the new API changes and
the Associated client libraries on our
developer pages and github to render
session off I would like to welcome
radder to the stage to tell us about how
the tools we have looked at are piteous
at Google
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Radha and I run
product operations for Android system
health my team is responsible for making
sure that all of Google's Android
developers can build excellent apps
quickly I'm here to talk to you about
some of the lessons we've learned in
working with Google's many app developer
teams how we use some of the tools
you've heard about today and why we love
them Google has many Android apps some
of them you may have heard about like
Gmail Maps YouTube or search would serve
billions of users but we actually have
over a hundred and 50 apps many of which
are just starting out and have a few
hundred or a few thousand users some of
these apps have small developer teams up
to ten people total
while others have hundreds or even
thousands of Googlers working on them in
this room as well there's probably a
similar diversity in terms of how big
teams are and how many users you serve
smaller apps are looking for ways to
scale rapidly to a growing user base and
larger apps are looking for ways to
innovate safely and quickly in working
with Google's teams we've found that
even this vast range of apps have a few
things in common each of these apps is
constantly evolving
each is looking to add new and exciting
features and adapt quickly to user
feedback and they would all rather avoid
that bad update and all of the
implications that we heard about earlier
what I'll be walking through today is
how we've come to a line on some common
tools and best practices that scale from
the smallest to the largest
apps so if we go back to our key points
on releases we need to make sure that we
can listen to our users
and the feedback they give us we need to
make sure we can maintain validate and
improve the key user and business
metrics and we need to optimize the
technology to avoid bugs and performance
issues and to support the incredible
diversity of users and devices out there
how do we map this to Google and how do
we scale and as teams grow in size and
ambition how do we continue to achieve
good release attributes while still
moving quickly
well we've developed some rules of the
road for how we can do testing and app
updates using the tools we've heard
about today we have developed a few
strategies to create a consistent
process that scales even to the
deployment of our largest apps I'll be
going over some of the strategies that
Google app developers are taking
advantage of to test out new features
and to release the next versions of
their apps first let's take a look at
testing we used to test by always
putting the raw most bleeding-edge
features into our alpha track this
ensured that the team could stay in tune
with each other and with the latest and
greatest as we made progress
unfortunately as the team grew this led
to an issue that we called you did what
to my VP demo teams need to be able to
move quickly to experiment and
occasionally break stuff but product
managers need fresh at most a day old
stable bills to show off the latest
features to executives and other
stakeholders we might need a stable
binary let's say to do an IO demo that
has a lot of the new features with more
testing tracks we're now able to give
individual teams their own builds where
they can experiment
independently of each other and
independently of the release process
they can deploy daily or even hourly if
they wish to share the latest features
among themselves we can also set the
country availability of the testing
tracks to global to allow Googlers in
any country to test their apps even if
the released product is not yet
available globally more tracks also
allow us to have a more thorough testing
process at release time thanks to
individual team tracks new features have
already been tested independently even
before we cut our release once we're
ready to release we promote our build
through multiple stages of testing
starting with a team wide test of tens
of people to a Google wide test with
thousands of users and then a public
open beta with potentially millions of
test users our open betas allow external
users to try our latest and greatest
features if they're willing to give us
private feedback on if they find they
like it or if they find the ride is a
little bumpy at first we imagined that
we might have a hard time getting users
to sign up for this but users can join
direct from the store listing in the
Play Store app and some of our apps now
have millions of users in their open
betas with additional testing tracks at
our disposal more and more google apps
are setting up an open beta this quote
shows how the Google Search app is
benefiting from the open beta program it
also highlights that testing is not just
about mitigating the risk of bugs and
crashes but it's also a chance to get
feedback on features and to ensure that
the new features have the right impact
on key performance indicators
you might be wondering what we get from
all of these various stages of testing
why not just go straight to open beta
well we might want to test out some
confidential new features before they
are visible to external users why do we
have both a team wide test and a Google
wide test at Google we have a tradition
of dogfooding our own products and we'd
rather not break Gmail for all Googlers
in our tests so why do we still need the
open beta if we have so many Googlers
testing well it's because even if a
Google wide test can reach thousands of
users by and large these users tend to
have a somewhat narrow set of Android
devices an open beta gives us much more
scale and the device set that is much
more representative of our production
users so that's testing we've validated
our features and our app update let's
move on to talk about how we actually
roll out these updates and features to
users a staged rollout is critically
important to Google teams rather than
updating two billion devices in one go
we always start small and ramp up
incrementally keeping a close eye on
business user and Krash metrics at the
first sign of any issues we can always
halt a release
but how do we actually manage these
releases one method we tried from
managing an app release was to wait
until all the features scheduled for
that release were ready then cut and
roll out the release this worked great
at first but unfortunately features
sometimes just sometimes hit a snag
causing delays to all the other features
scheduled for the release soon the main
release becomes the June release and now
you're pulling more and more features
into that single release more features
means more testing more bugs more
release candidates more changes that
make it hard to track down exactly what
caused any particular bug or performance
regression and since the next release
might be a while away developers
scramble to get their features on board
the release train and then in the
meantime you discover you need to ship
an urgent bug fix that just can't wait
and as you can see as the team scales
this tends to spiral waiting for all
features to be ready slows down
innovation and adds a lot of risk to the
app release we found that
counter-intuitively faster is safer
keeping a continuous and predictable
release train makes each release smaller
safer and easier to manage those urgent
bug fixes can be sure to go out on time
and interestingly knowing that the next
release is only a few weeks away
developers tend to avoid cramming
they're almost but not quite finished
features into a given release so this is
a great philosophy but how does it work
in practice how do we keep the trains
running on time and how do we ensure
that new features don't go live before
they're ready to get features out safely
in an app release
use a technique called flag guarded
feature development whenever possible we
try to avoid shipping new features
directly with an app update we put each
feature behind a flag that can be
toggled on and off from the server first
we use the staged rollout to release the
app update with all the flags turned off
by first deploying such a change neutral
binary it's easier and safer to get this
update to all 100% of our users this
also allows us to evaluate the
application binary itself for things
like stability and system health as it
installs on the user's device separately
from the feature and how the feature is
doing once this change neutral app
update is safely deployed we can then
slowly enable each feature by turning on
the flags again carefully keeping an eye
on all of those important user business
and crash metrics to detect any issues
if we find an issue we always have the
option to disable the feature by turning
off the flag importantly keeping these
features behind flags and first
deploying a change neutral binary means
that any issue with one feature won't
adversely affect all the other features
in the app update I like to think of
this as satellite deployment not that
I've ever actually deployed a satellite
but step one is to get the thing into
orbit
once it's safely in orbit then you can
unpack each instrument one by one you
can achieve this in your own app using
firebase remote config the Google Search
app is one of many Google teams that
have scaled their release process and
their feature launches using flag
guarded development
so you might be wondering how long
releases take if we're going through
each of these stages of testing and ramp
up because the released rain stays
predictable we're usually able to
deliver most app updates to users within
a couple of weeks while having the
ability to speed up a release if
absolutely necessary for the larger apps
the ones that have more than a billion
users we're able to collect enough data
to have confidence in our releases
within a couple of days these release
best practices help us keep each of our
150-plus apps at Google high-quality
without ever putting the brakes on how
fast we can innovate and bring fresh and
exciting features to our billions of
users worldwide so that was a tour
through the Google release process I
hope you found this useful
and that there's some ideas that you can
put to use in your own release process
and I'd like to welcome Mike back on
stage through clothes things off
thanks Radha so to recap we've seen why
releasing is an exciting time and how we
like to think about what constitutes a
great release a release that delights
users improves business metrics and is
stable and performant
after this we took a look through the
suite of tools that the Google Play
console makes available to help you
achieve efficient well understood risk
free app releases we look to the new
internal testing track for fast
iterative testing with your team and
testers we looked at close testing where
you the developer get to control exactly
who can test your app we've seen how
Google Play is going beyond alpha beta
with additional closed testing tracks
and of course open testing where any
user can opt in to test your app direct
from the Google Play Store we've seen
how this can bring huge scale TR testing
we also looked at rolling out your
releases with improvements to the
releases UI improvements to staged
rollout and the new improve publishing
API for more automation of your release
using Gradle and continuous integration
tools and we took a whirlwind tour
through Google's approach to creating a
consistent release process that scales
from the smallest to the largest teams
we hope you find this talk useful please
do give these tools ago and let us know
what you think we look forward to
hearing your feedback as you use these
tools more and more if you'd like to
share your experiences or you have
thoughts or ideas on how how we could
make these tools even better please do
come and see us in the Android and play
sandbox
in dome C thank you
[Music]
[Applause]